so we're given four different equations
here and each of them have a blank and
we need to fill in that blank with a
missing number so let's do each of these
so on the left hand side of this
equation we have one plus four and that
is equal to so one plus four is the same
thing as well one plus four is five
if we take four and if you add one more
you're going to have five so now we
finish that one because one plus four is
the same thing as five now here we're
saying four plus something is the same
thing as five well we just figured out
that one plus four or four plus 1 is the
same thing as five so four plus one is
five
so notice that we have the equation four
plus 1 is the same thing as five equals
means that what's on the left is the
same thing as what you have on the right
now we have blank plus two is equal to
five so what plus two is the same thing
as five well three plus two is equal to
five or five is equal to three plus two
now you go here well now they have three
plus blank is equal to five well we
already figured it out because three
plus two is equal to five so we could
write three plus two is equal to five
that we could check ourselves and then
we could keep going so now we have some
subtraction so what's the same thing as
nine minus three so if I have nine
things and if I were to take away three
of them I'm going to have six left nine
minus three is the same thing as six ten
minus blank is equal to six
so what do I have to take away from ten
in order to have six left over well if I
take far away from ten I'm going to have
six left over now something minus one is
the same thing as six well seven minus
one is going to be equal to six and then
we get 8 minus blank is equal to six so
how many do have to take away from eight
in order to get to six well if I take
away one I'm going to get seven if I
take away two I'm going to have 6 so 8
minus two is equal to six